♪ (intro music) ♪
I want to talk to you about something
that's very important to me.
And that's, how will civilization
power itself for the next 100 years?
So, in 2100,
the projected world's population
is 11.2 billion.
If all 11.2 billion people
want to enjoy the same
power usage that we do now,
in the United States,
that's going to require burning
around 0.2 yottajoules of energy
over the next 100 years.
So, that's a whole lot.
To put that into perspective--
if we wanted to do that with oil alone,
we'd have to ramp up oil production
by a factor of 10 for the next 100 years.
So there's no way that's going to happen.
So, besides being infeasible,
that would contribute
to catastrophic climate change.
If we want to keep climate change
to a level that's not ideal,
but at least reasonable--
say, under 2 degrees
of temperature increase--
then only 8% of that 0.2 yottajoules
can come from fossil fuels,
like coal or oil.
So where does the other 92% come from?
One possible source
would be nuclear fusion.
Fusion involves pushing together
two smaller nuclei,
and what you get out
is a whole lot of energy,
and no greenhouse gas.
So, right now, the sun
runs on nuclear fusion.
And the reaction is so energy-dense
that the 0.2 yottajoules would require
say, a trivial amount
of deuterium found in seawater.
Or say, just seven months
of the world's current boron production--
so a very trivial amount of boron.
So far it sounds
like some sort of miracle fuel.
Well, what's the catch?
The difficulty is that people
have been trying this for 70 years,
and so far, no one has gotten
out more energy than they put in.
So, to understand this,
you have to imagine that the--
well, the reaction takes place
inside of a plasma.
And a plasma is a million plus
degree swarm of charged particles.
And these particles
don't want to stay in place.
The sun uses a gravitational force
to keep everything in place.
We can't do that;
so instead, we use magnets.
Now, magnets--
you try to squeeze it with magnets
and they can pop out the end.
And you can get little turbulent ripples,
and what happens is the plasma breaks up,
it gets unstable, it gets cooler,
and then the reaction stops.
And that's what's been happening
for 70 years.
So this is the kind
of problem that I like:
it combines physics, probability,
computation, mathematics.
And so, that was like,
"I want to work on this
and how can we accelerate progress?"
Google is not building a fusion reactor.
(laughter)
What we have done is we've partnered
with TAE Technologies.
And this is the world's largest
private fusion energy company.
And we've been working
with them since 2015.
So, pictured here
is their 5th-generation
plasma generation device.
And this thing is huge--
it would fill up
a large part of this room.
And then in the center
is where the plasma is kept.
This is an elongated toroid,
and the goal, really, is to keep
this in its place and prevent turbulence.
And if it gets out of place,
then the reaction stops.
So there's magnets and neutral beams,
and a host of other technologies
to keep it in place.
Now, what's Google's job specifically?
Well, our goal is to take the measurements
that come from this experimental reactor.
And every time the physicists
do an experiment,
within five minutes we want to tell them
the plasma density, temperature,
and magnetic field
on a three-dimensional grid.
So, how hard is that?
Well, first of all,
the plasma is very, very hot.
So you can't just poke
it with a thermometer, like a turkey.
The thermometer would melt,
and you would disrupt the plasma
and ruin the experiment.
So what you do have
are measurements along the boundary.
But there's only so many
measurements you can take,
because you can't cut that many holes
on the side of this device.
So, let's look closely at one--
let's look at measuring
of electron density,
and that's done with a device
known as an interferometer.
An interferometer shines lasers
through the plasma,
and then the phase shift is proportional
to the average electron density
along that ray.
So, we have 14 lasers shining through
the center of the plasma.
So we know the average density
along 14 lines.
And from that, we want
to know the density everywhere.
So clearly, there's no one
unique solution to this problem.
And instead, we'll have
a distribution over possible solutions.
So, we do this in a Bayesian sense,
and our final output
will be a probability density function
for the density of the electrons,
given the measurements.
And we can visualize that with a graph--
where you have the mean
and some error bars.
How does TensorFlow help with this?
So, the first place is translating
measurement physics into code.
So, let's consider the distribution
for the camera measurement.
So, the cameras measure photons.
And say we have some photons
that are being emitted from the plasma.
The mean number of photons
reaching the camera is given
by a tf.sparse_tensor_dense_matmul.
But we don't actually realize the mean--
instead what we realize is a noisy mean.
So there's noise due to a finite number
of photons-- that's Poisson noise.
We also have discretization noise,
because we discretize space.
So, the TensorFlow distributions library
gives you access
to this normal distribution object,
so that this noisy flux
represents a normal distribution--
it has a mean, you can draw samples,
you can compute the PDF, and so on.
Then, that's not all, though.
We also have analog
to digital conversion process
that we model as passing
this normal distribution
through a non-linear response curve,
and then digitizing it to 8 bits.
So, at the end, this digitized_charge
is another distribution object
that has an ability to take samples,
you can compute the probability
mass function because it's discrete,
and so on.
And since we want to be Bayesian,
we can reassemble
a number of these distributions,
giving us a likelihood
and a prior, and so on.
It's with a goal of producing a posterior.
And then we do Bayesian inference--
so now to do inference,
we do this in two different ways.
The first way is variational inference,
which amounts
to minimizing a loss function.
And by minimizing a loss function
you get an approximation
of the true posterior.
So, this minimization is done
just like any other
TensorFlow minimization--
for example, we use AdamOptimizer.
The second way is using
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo.
So, the TensorFlow probability library
gives you access to a number
of Monte Carlo samplers,
and the Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
is one that uses gradients
in order to help you take samples faster.
Notice, in both cases,
we're using auto differentiation here,
whether we're taking
gradients of this loss--
or whether we're taking gradients
to do Hamiltonian Monte Carlo sampling.
So, popping up a level, you'll notice
we're not doing deep learning.
Instead, we're doing an inverse problem
whereby measurements,
given to us from physicists,
are translated into a reconstruction
of some physical state.
So, there's a few differences
I want to highlight.
First of all, there are no labels
that are given to us.
The natural label here
would be a three-dimensional image
of the actual plasma.
But we're the ones who are telling people
what the plasma looks like,
so we're the ones
actually producing the labels.
Given that there's no labels,
you might be tempted to say,
"Well, this is an unsupervised
learning technique, like word clustering."
There's a key difference, though,
that here there really is a right answer,
there really was a plasma out there,
and if that plasma doesn't fall
within our error bars,
we've made a mistake.
And also, you'll notice
that our graph here models physics
rather than generic functions.
So, it's a bit more constrained
than these deep neural networks,
but that allows us to get
the right answer with no labels.
At the end of the day, TensorFlow,
despite it not being deep learning,
TensorFlow adds value
with the TensorFlow distributions
and probability library.
We have auto differentiation
to do inference.
And in order to provide answers
to many measurements at once,
GPUs and distributed
computing is very important.
So, thank you very much.
(applause)
♪ (outro music) ♪